but it's not crocodiles I should have
been watching out for
instead it's one of the most
temperamental animals out here
wow there are a lot of eyes looking in
my direction a lot of ears pointed in my
direction they know I'm here
hippos kill more people than
any other large animal in the entire
world
so packed together in such limited water
they're stressed and ready to defend
their territory
look at that one
it's starting to come up starting to
come up
just showing me their jaws showing me
their tusks
that could literally cut a man in half
they're telling me to back off
hippos are dangerous in and out of the
water
they can run up to 22 miles an hour and
in this area I need to keep a lookout
everywhere around me
here's what I'm talking about
the ones that are up on land
those are just on the land feeding which
means there could be more out here
that's when they get really dangerous
okay time to go
[Music]
thank you